my baby's gone
i can't it's hard
the mother of amari nicholson is
speaking out publicly
for the first time since the arrest of
the man accused of killing her child
taylor nicholson talked with the
i-team's vanessa murphy and addressed
suspicions and criticism
vanessa's here live in studio now
joining us with more
brian taylor nicholson insists she
trusted her ex-boyfriend
and didn't initially believe he harmed
her child
she says she is just a grieving mother
no charges have been brought against her
the clark county district attorney tells
me investigators found
nothing criminal on the mother's part
she showed up in court today as terrell
rhodes case was called
today he was not brought into the
courtroom as expected
he faces a murder charge metro police
say he confessed to beating the
two-year-old to death and then hid
his body police found amari's remains
wednesday
one week after he was first reported
missing and rhodes claimed a woman
took him how come it was important for
you to come to court today
because this man betrayed me
he hurt me he took my whole purpose of
life away from me
and i don't want him to sit back and
think that
he's going to get this at all easy he
took a precious child away from many
people
and he needs to pay attention to how we
all feel because this is not ok
rhodes is facing additional charges
after police say he fought with them
and grabbed an officer's gun d-a steve
wolfson says his office is also
considering
attempted murder charges for that i also
asked if his office will seek the death
penalty for terrell rhodes
he says it's just too early to tell
right now you can watch the full
interview with taylor nicholson
at 8newsnow.com